It belonged to my teacher
master yoda if you choose the armor you'll
return to your friend the mandalorian
but if you choose the lightsaber you will be the
first student in my academy which do you choose
welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
grogu luke skywalker video for the book of boba
fett in the mandalorian season 3 why they're
setting up grogu leaving luke skywalker's new
jedi order is jedi temple the academy after
he just got there if you're brand new to the
channel i'll be doing videos for the mandalorian
season 3 and obi-wan kenobi episodes real soon
everything else this year be sure to subscribe
to get them all there are going to be a lot of
star wars episodes coming this year careful
for spoilers for everything that's happened
on the book of boba fett so far if you have
not been watching the show it has been kind
of like the mandalorian season 2.5 for the last
couple episodes but recently during the book of
boba fett episode 5 and episode 6 we just learned
what grogu and the mandalorian din jarn have been
doing since the end of the mandalorian season 2
episode 8 finale grogu left with luke skywalker
to begin his jedi training and mando had left
with the darksaber to find the armor and his
former cover to mandalorians because he still has
the darksaber that effectively gives him a claim
to the throne of their home planet mandalore in
the title of mandalore which is what they call
the ruler of their people at any given time in
grogu had been training with luke skywalker on
the planet where he eventually creates his jedi
temple his academy that we've seen in the movies
luke barely having just begun to construct the
actual physical temple itself and he'd intended
for grogu to become his very first student at the
new jedi academy and even though ahsoka tano was
also at the jedi academy they weren't trying to
say that she was going to become an instructor at
the academy she was just there for a brief stay to
meet with luke skywalker and see grogu begin his
training and then go off on her own mission that
we'll cover during the ahsoka episodes in that
series next year just because luke skywalker's
beginning his new jedi academy doesn't mean that
ahsoka is coming back to the jedi order and that
also kind of dovetails with the reason why grogu
will eventually lead the jedi academy it was a
great episode it featured a lot of easter eggs
and callbacks to luke skywalker's jedi training
with yoda during empire strikes back in a lot
of the exact same scenes running around in the
little go-to-sized backpack learning to levitate
balancing himself using the force while doing
multiple things at the same time him learning
to dodge the training drone's blaster fire was
more of a reference to yoda's force jumping and
lightsaber fighting skills during attack of the
clones and revenge of the sith and for obi-wan
kenobi's training of luke during a new hope
including the size matters not speech this is them
showing you some of the things that grogu can do
we saw some of his skills during the mandalorian
season too like force choking and throwing around
the stormtroopers so he is very powerful and luke
was helping him unlock a lot of his prior training
with the jedi that he'd suppressed even though we
only saw them training for this one episode it's
implied that grogu and luke skywalker have been
training like this for months and just in terms
of timeline between the end of the mandalorian
season 2 in the book of boba fett episode one
it's been less than a year not that much time
has passed like a little bit of time but that's it
you probably see where i'm going with this grogu
was training with luke skywalker for about as long
maybe even a little bit longer than luke skywalker
actually trained with yoda before he left to
go rescue han solo princess leia the others
at cloud city when he got the forced vision of
them in trouble and even though grogu didn't get
a forced vision of mando being in trouble during
the episode they tried to show you how ahsoka had
to counsel mando about jedi attachment issues and
remind him what it did to anakin skywalker leading
to him becoming darth vader going to the dark side
of the force she basically explained why she and
luke skywalker were trying to do everything
they could to avoid repeating that mistake
and at the end of the episode they show grogu is
just as preoccupied missing mando not focusing on
his training as much as he should which is also
meant to be another parallel for anakin skywalker
yoda had his own version of this speech during
empire strikes back speaking about anakin
skywalker and luke skywalker like his father
never his mind on where he was what he was doing
that's what ahsoka's comment about anakin
skywalker meant when she told luke much like your
father the devil meaning was that she was saying
that luke was much like his father trying to
train a padawan for the first time like ahsoka was
anakin's first padawan but ahsoka was also telling
luke that she sees a lot of the same energy in
grogu that she saw in anakin skywalker which is
kind of a warning and this also dovetails with why
they'll have grogu make the choice to leave luke
skywalker's jedi academy and it's all about the
mistakes of the jedi the way that the jedi dogma
kind of set them up to fail like we talk about the
fall of the jedi and as evil as emperor palpatine
and the sith were a lot of the things that the
jedi wound up doing a lot of their teachings
were actually wrong just in a completely different
direction george lucas talked a lot about this
about anakin skywalker bringing balance to the
force and as much as that was about getting rid
of the emperor during return of the jedi bringing
balance to the force was also about getting rid of
the jedi order as it existed when anakin skywalker
became darth vader the idea that even though the
jedi themselves weren't evil a lot of their
teachings were wrong at the end of the episode
luke skywalker forces grogu to make the choice
between the mandalorian and the jedi choose the
mandalorians best car armor chainmail suit or
choose yoda's lightsaber in the path of the jedi
if he chooses the armor he forsakes the path
of the jedi as luke skywalker sees it and if
he chooses yoda's lightsaber luke is effectively
saying you won't ever see the mandalorian again
it will take you many years to master the ways
of force and you may never see the mandalorian
again a lot of you were commenting about how it's
lame for luke to make him choose like why make
him choose why can't he have both the armor and
the lightsaber and the reason why they actually
wrote it this way why they had luke skywalker do
this is to show you how luke is repeating a lot of
the same mistakes as the jedi order with their
rigid dogma about attachments and he's sort of
setting up his jedi academy to eventually fail
remember during episode five when mando had the
darksaber and was talking to the armor about
grogu and she told him the same speech about
jedi dogma and attachments mando argued that their
philosophy as mandalorians was almost the opposite
it was all about attachment and protecting your
clan protecting your family that is the opposite
of our creed loyalty and solidarity are the way
and you have to remember that mando is not on
the path to the dark side or anything like he is
a little bit darker as a character but they want
you to think that he's walking the correct path
like he might make some short-term mistakes but
in the larger sense of things he's on the right
path whereas luke skywalker is just repeating
the same mistakes of the old jedi order we saw
how that ended not well and while jon favreau
and dave filoni aren't retconning any of the new
star wars movies or anything they are preemptively
sidestepping them using grogu and here's how
they're doing that grogu will eventually leave
luke skywalker in the jedi order but luke
helped him unlock his previous jedi training
making him much more powerful giving him access
to more memories that he can continue to relearn
jedi skills from so he's just beginning to do that
now and because yoda's species lives for up to
900 years or so grogu's only a little over 50 now
he's got over 800 years to develop his own version
of a new jedi order that's totally different from
the old jedi order so when choosing the bheskar
armor they're basically saying grogu is going
to reject the old jedi ways that luke skywalker
is hyping up in this episode so eventually
someday when mando dies either of old age or
he dies in some big battle and grogu goes his own
way focusing more on deepening his connection with
the force he'll start a new jedi order of his own
and because this is more than 50 plus years in the
future we're probably talking about here unless
mando gets killed really soon that puts grogu
way past the events of the new star wars movies
effectively sidestepping everything that happened
during the new movies grogu off on his own with
the help of force ghost yoda maybe counseling him
or anybody that's still alive at that point maybe
force ghost ahsoka pretty much all the jedi that
you know right now would be force ghost by that
point right now grogu is the only character that
we know of that we've seen in the context of
the show and the movies who will still be alive
a long time in the future creating a new different
jedi academy one that doesn't focus so much on
absolutes or attachment issues there were a lot
of jokes about this too after luke skywalker made
him choose why is he making him choose only
a sith deal on absolutes if you haven't seen
any of the star wars rebels episodes either they
introduced the bendu character during that played
by tom baker of doctor who fame and the bendu was
a creature that wasn't a jedi or a sith he wasn't
a grey jedi either but he wielded both the dark
side and the light side of the force in a more
complete way that made him way more powerful and i
think that eventually in the distant future of the
star wars universe grogu will become something
closer to the bendu even if he doesn't become
a dai bendu himself dai bendu is the name of the
order that the bendu belonged to is a big easter
egg for that which is actually a big easter egg
for george lucas's original treatment for the
star wars universe also if you read a lot of
the classic comics there was this idea of the
original order of force users that pre-dated the
jedi order in the sith they kind of did the same
thing they wielded both dark side and light
sides of the force at the same time but they
had a huge schism in their order a big civil war
splitting them apart half went to form the jedi
the other half went to form the dark side force
users that would eventually be known as the sith
also when talking about grogu leaving luke
skywalker's jedi academy there were a lot of
practical easter eggs and references in the
previous episode foreshadowing him leaving
like the little tiny pod they created in the naboo
n1 starfighter the grogu size pod that they kept
focusing the camera on when characters talked
about grogu as for the fate of yoda's lightsaber
if grogu leaves would luke still let him keep it
i know a lot of you like will they still let him
have the lightsaber even if he takes off it's
always possible but if the idea is that grogu
is gonna leave to forge a totally new jedi path a
new jedi order that's different from the old ways
i'd rather see him create his own lightsaber
eventually that's just totally different also
if you're talking about yoda's lightsaber even
though it is tiny i mean it's a really cute little
lightsaber grogu's tiny little hands still are
not big enough to completely reach around yoda's
lightsaber hilt so physically it would actually
be very difficult for him to wield the lightsaber
he could grab lightsabers like the darksaber or
even yoda's lightsaber with the force and swing
it around that way but physically he couldn't
reach his hand around the hilt and swing it
around like you would normally do even though
he doesn't have the technical knowledge in how
to actually build a lightsaber force ghost yoda
or ahsoka tano could teach him how to do that
if you saw the deleted scenes for return of the
jedi they also have the deleted scene of luke
skywalker building his new green lightsaber he
didn't get special plans on how to build that he
got some help from force ghost obi-wan kenobi in
yoda so they can do the same thing for grogu in
the distant future when he eventually creates his
own lightsaber also ahsoka tano would know how to
build a lightsaber she could tell grogu how to do
that too so there are other force users out there
who are still alive that grogu can still learn new
things from while he's having adventures with the
mandalorian during season 3 and beyond post all
your theories in the comments below do you think
that grogu will leave the jedi academy and someday
create a totally different kind of jedi order my
full book of boba fett episode 7 finale video will
post next week that's right the finale is next
week we'll get some teasers for the mandalorian
season 3 during that so i'll also do some separate
videos for those after the episode comes out click
here for my full book of boba fett episode 6 video
probably the best episode so far and click here
for my new marvel doctor strange 2 iron man video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!